[Música]
hay parques de atracciones hechos de en
francia este es por supuesto el caso en
el parque de astérix donde la gente hace
fila desde por la mañana para una foto
con dos superhéroes muy franceses
astérix y obélix esta familia de nantes
vino disfrazada de galos los trajes son
hechos en casa es el primer parque de
atracciones para nuestros hijos así que
queríamos celebrarlo como debe ser aquí
se viene por las sensaciones fuertes
estas máquinas están entre las más
espectaculares de francia
como esté osiris del nombre de un dios
del antiguo egipto que preside el juicio
de los muertos es cierto que estar a 40
metros de altura propulsado a 90
kilómetros por hora parece un poco como
estar al borde de la muerte en cada
curva
en este parque único en el mundo la
famosa tira cómica está hasta en los
platos
es como la carne del cerdo tienes que
cocinar la vía no podemos vender la roja
si no habría un riesgo de infección
bacteriana
el jabalí puede comerse como una
hamburguesa el sabor es más pronunciado
no es una hamburguesa de carne clásica
si no dejaba libras así que es muy buena
salud y aquí está la mayor estrella del
parque y de fix nos recibe en su
camerino
es un pequeño west y por eso lo elegimos
la raza idefics no existe hacemos que se
vea lo más similar posible recortando el
pelo de cierta manera y teniendo las
orejas y la cola que se va a entrenar a
su perro en idefics desde hace cuatro
años es dócil astuto
y es esperado con impaciencia por el
público el dúo es la estrella del nuevo
espectáculo el parque que acaba de
celebrar su aniversario número 30 debe
innovar constantemente para seguir
atrayendo a casi 10.000 galos cada día
[Aplausos]
un poco más al norte en la costa del
ópalo otro parque de atracciones pero
más pequeño bagatela entre los tres y
desde los años ochenta bagatelle es una
religión a la que los abuelos y padres
han convertido a los niños embarque
inmediato y acuático para los jóvenes
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cómo pasamos
bagatelle es un negocio familiar el
parque nació en 1955 fue fundado por el
abuelo del actual director estas son
imágenes de las diferentes épocas de
bagatela el primer tren citó en el lago
con los botes de pedales fue el comienzo
de los grandes parques maga t él abrió
dos meses antes que disney y en eeuu no
se conocían los parques de atracciones
este lugar siempre ha sido un lago en
absoluto estamos en un viejo aeródromo
militar durante la guerra los alemanes
estaban allí eran hoyos de bomba
mi abuelo aprovechó la oportunidad para
abrirlo todo y crear un estanque el agua
sigue siendo el elemento fuerte de este
parque de 26 hectáreas el lugar también
ha podido destacar al aceptar los perros
se ha ganado la lealtad de sus dueños
conozco a todo el mundo los empleados la
gente del parque y conozco a todo el
mundo con el perro se me nota
y eso es lo que es tan especial de
bagatelle 65 años de existencia un
público fiel un parque a escala humana y
el año pasado más de 320 mil visitantes
otro parque es el orgullo de su región
pero este mira hacia el futuro
[Música]
la señal
bienvenido al futuro escogió de
cualquier la atracción más popular del
parque promete un viaje extraordinario
marín text ya ha estado al frente de la
atracción durante tres años
frente a una pantalla gigante esta
plataforma que se inclina a 190 grados
es única en europa es un trabajo de
primera categoría
todos los días viajamos la música es
hermosa después de 30 años de existencia
el parque debe innovar constantemente
para mantenerse fiel a su reputación no
negamos nuestras raíces estamos hechos
de imágenes tecnología innovaciones y
seguimos estando hechos de ellas lo que
cambia son las necesidades y deseos de
los visitantes añadimos más diversión y
todo es un poco pedagógico
como este programa de ilusión votado el
mejor en francia el año pasado
mago del futuro os copio durante 15 años
ver con los utiliza las más modernas
tecnologías para cautivar a su público
el parque del futuro os copio quiere
destacar y no seguir siendo un parque de
imágenes quiere ser un parque con futuro
una mezcla de técnicas y eso es lo que
hacemos en este programa
[Música]
está oscureciendo el último espectáculo
del día es un espectáculo acuático y
pirotécnico diseñado por el circo del
sol una bailarina real interactúa con un
gigante virtual aquí la atracción rima
con la ciencia ficción
[Música]